we've been extremely excited about
apple's upcoming 14 and 16-inch macbook
pros
ever since the m1 max were released back
in november
and have continued to prove that apple
absolutely made the right decision
by switching from intel over to their
very own
apple silicon chips and the craziest
part is that all of that happened
to the three low end max that didn't
receive
any changes other than the actual chip
itself
and the reason we're so excited is
because we're expecting
every single mac with apple silicon
moving forward
to get a complete redesign like the new
imacs
and especially the macbook pros but what
i want to focus on
in this video is the actual performance
of the chip
that's most likely going into the 14 and
16-inch macbook pro
when they get released sometime this
summer and the reason i'm doing this now
is because we finally got some
performance benchmark leaks
that actually seem realistic and match
up to the estimates that i
made based on the performance of the m1
chip
so before we get into those leaks let's
quickly go through the basics of the
m1x chip last year on december 3rd
i released a video discussing my
expectations for the 2021 mac roadmap
including the m1x chip which i said
would be getting a 12 core cpu
and a 16 core integrated gpu my
speculation was based on a very old
report from bloomberg
back in april stating that apple will
use a 12
core 5 nanometer arm chip in a 2021 mac
which is when they thought the very
first apple silicon mac would get
released
well it turned out that the very first
chip was actually the eight
core m1 that came back in november and
because of
that i still believe that the 12 core
version
is coming in the form of the m1x chip
this summer and if you're wondering why
i think it's going to be called the m1x
and not the m2 that's because the m2
name
is almost certainly going to be saved
for the model
with the next generation upgraded cores
built on a three
or four nanometer architecture from tsmc
and i don't think that's happening until
next year so because of that
i believe this new 12 core chip is going
to use the same exact
cores as we currently have in the m1
apple is simply going to add four more
high performance cores
and that's it and because the cores will
be staying the same
the one in the chip title needs to stay
there
so it's gonna be the m one again but
since this is an upgraded version
they're gonna add a letter to the end of
the title
and the one that makes the most sense is
x because apple used x in the past
for their ipad pro chips so i expect
apple to do the same thing
for the m1x since the actual cores
themselves
are identical and i believe that the
graphic scores
will be the same as well but it's going
to have 16 of them
instead of the current 8 and the m1 so
with that out of the way
let me get into how i estimated the
performance of the m1x
and then compare that to the leaked
benchmarks that i'm going to show you in
just a minute
since the m1x will be using the same
exact cores as the m1
i ended up calculating the score per
watt of each of the
individual cores under full sustained
load in cinebench r23
the m1 chip used a total of 14.3 watts
with 13 watts used by the four
performance cores
and just 1.3 watts used by the ford
efficiency course
we ended up getting a total score of
around 7 700
in that cpu benchmark so let's break the
score down
the four efficiency cores used 1.3 watts
which is about 10 of the power of the
four high performance cores so if we
take that 7700 score that we got
and divide it by 10 we end up getting
770 points
from those four efficiency cores and 7
000 points
from the performance course so now let's
take that and apply it to the 12
core m1x chip since that chip is gonna
have double the performance cores
eight instead of four we can take the
seven thousand points from the
performance course
and double it to get fourteen thousand
and then add in
the 770 points from the four efficiency
cores
for a total of fourteen thousand seven
hundred and seventy points
in cinebench r23 that score is
absolutely insane
because it beats out the 12 core desktop
chip
in the 2019 mac pro
and i know you guys are going to say
that you can't just double the score of
the performance cores
because it doesn't scale linearly but
everything is different for apple
silicon
the current m1 chip doesn't even get
close to throttling in the m1 macbook
pro
in fact the fan barely even turns on
after a 10 minute cinebench r23 run and
because of that
i think the 12 core m1x chip is not
gonna throttle either
because the cooling system will be even
better
on the higher end macbook pros so i
think our estimates are totally
realistic
and with that let's take a look at the
benchmark leaks that we recently
received
on the benchmarking website cpu monkey
which showed that the m1x will be
getting a 12 core cpu
and a 16 core gpu layout as we expected
and according to the leaked benchmarks
they're showing the m1x getting 14 450
points
in cinebench r23 which is very close to
our estimate
of 14 770 and surprisingly
that score outperforms the i9
10 900 x desktop chip from intel
which is crazy impressive now some
people have said that that leak was fake
but i actually believe it could be true
because last year a few days before the
apple silicon mac event
cpu monkey actually leaked the
performance of the a14x
chip which is what we thought the m1
would have been named but of course
it ended up being the m1 the leaked
numbers although very optimistic
at the time ended up being really close
to the true performance that we got with
the m1
and then on top of that just the other
day john prosser said that these
m1x leaks from cpu monkey are legit
so because of all of that i think that
we can trust
that 14 450 score for the m1x
and to make this score even crazier it
actually beats out the brand new
ryzen 5900 hx chip from
amd which is said to be the fastest
laptop
chip ever made but it scored about 1350
points
less than this leaked m1x score so with
that out of the way
let's get into the graphics side of the
performance and according to cpu monkey
the m1x's 16 core gpu has around
5.2 teraflops of performance
basically putting it on par with the
very best
radeon pro 5600m graphics option
in the 16-inch macbook pro which by the
way
carries a massive 800 price tag
for that upgrade alone however it seems
like the benchmark leak from cpu monkey
is just an estimate since all they did
was double the performance of the m1
but i actually think that we can
realistically expect
a doubling in performance because of the
efficiency
of the new apple silicon architecture
and if you don't believe me
let me prove it to you the a12 z chip in
the 2020 ipad pro
with an 8 core gpu is able to get
over two times the performance of the
a12 chip
with a 4 core gpu and keep in mind
that they're using the same exact course
the same thing happened with the a10x
chips 12 core gpu
getting over double the graphics
performance of the a10 chip's
six-core gpu once again using the same
exact course
so based on apple's past trends with
graphics performance
i expect the m1x's 16 core gpu
to literally double the performance of
the m1 chip's 8 core gpu
so with that in mind i personally
estimated the m1x
to score around 45 000 points in
geekbench 5's metal test
which basically makes it almost as
powerful as a dedicated
gtx 1080 max q graphics card
built into a modern laptop what i'm
pretty much trying to say is that the
m1x chip
is not only gonna be the fastest laptop
chip ever made but it's actually going
to outperform
a lot of the high-end desktop systems in
terms of processing power
and it's going to have just enough
graphics performance
to play some aaa games without requiring
an egpu which is awesome
so with that said if you've been
thinking about buying a new macbook pro
i would definitely wait for the 14 and
16 inch models coming this summer
because both of them should be able to
get the m1x chip
with its crazy performance hopefully you
enjoyed this video and if you did go
ahead and tap the like button
and if you disagree with my speculations
comment down below
and click the circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video